qu'il s'appellent Barkley Zavata ou que
leur nom est récemment déffrayé la
chronique ils parlent tous pour la
première fois de leur étonnante histoire
de famille faitti de manque ou de trop
plein d'amour paternel Lydia et waren
zavat donc fille et Petitfils du Grand
de l'immense clown aschil Z avata
séducteur
aussi tombeur ou et oui a eu trois
mariages TR fois 20 ans quand même C
fois moins que monsur ouioui
20 ans à chaque fois Guillaume ça durait
pas 20 ans à chaque
fois des broutilles c'est ça que vous
dites
débroutill jusqu'à l'âge de 13 ans ça a
été un paradis pour moi parce que
j'étais je servais de partenaire à mon
père j'étais partout dans les galas au
cierc d'hiver un peu partout et après
après il y a eu effectivement des femmes
qui venaient de Paris qui je voyais papa
qui partait à l'hôtel et tout ça et puis
après j'ai vu les les maîtresses qui qui
venait et puis maman maman qui pleurait
maman qui a voulu mourir maman qui a
voulu se
suicider tout ça je je je me vois encore
parler à une une maîtresse de mon père
en lui disant écoute quitte le cirque
va-t-en et cette fille m'a dit je je
veux pas partir j'aime ton père voilà
alors j'ai j'ai beaucoup souffert de de
tout ça et puis ouis ça été assez
violent dans ce que vous racontez oui
oui oui oui j'ai beaucoup souffert de ça
bon après je sais pas s'il s à saagim
enfin
le temps où j'étais avec lui vraiment il
il était très coureur voilà ben on n'est
pas là pour juger ses parents de toute
façon il y a eu du bon il y a eu du
mauvais et je me souviens surtout du bon
et toi moi je me souviens surtout du
mauvais c'est
marrant vre grandpère moi c'est mon
grand-père donc j'ai très peu de
souvenirs et il faut que je dise que
Lydia pardon est votre tante hein il
s'est pas intéressé à moi ni à mon frère
ni à ma
parce qu'en plus c'est quelquun que tout
le monde s'appropriaitav c'était le
clown et nous on a pas ça on a que ce
côté alors vous en avez fait un
spectacle formidable formidable vraiment
j'ai pas fait un spectacle sur mon
grand-père non mais sur les coulisses du
cirque en général sur ma vie
aussiavisme je trouve ça vraiment
formidable formidable qu'il ait pu
exprimer les les deux côtés les deux
facettes du du personnage waren
finalement vous criez l'abandon mais en
même temps l'admiration et l'amour oui
c'est cette relation amour haine oui
c'est c'est très proche l'un de l'autre
l'amour et la haine c'est très proche on
aurait tellement
souhaité profiter encore plus de lui
quoi c'est ça de oui pardon non moi j'ai
vu son spectacle et il m'a bluffé et ce
qui est très troublant c'est qu'on
d'abord on rigole beaucoup ça c'est vrai
on rigole beaucoup et parfois un moment
on a honte de rigoler parce qu'on sent
qu'il dit des trucs graves ou s
qume on se dit là là là peut-être que je
devrais pas rire alors que effectivement
la situation est drôle mais elle est
troublante parce que on se dit mais ça a
dû vraiment pas être facile tous les
jours c'est clair il y a vraiment une
fure moi j'ai la la blessure est
derrière le rire quoi ouais quand vous
dites ahin Zavata a fait rêver tout le
monde mais moi il a pourri mon enfance
c'est vrai que vous tenez des propos
forts parce que je me rappelle très bien
du procès qu'il a fait à ses enfants il
m'a refusé du travail quand j'avais 18
19 ans ça c'est un truc qui m'avait et
il a été ENF a pas étaé présent et moi
j'ai vraiment souffert de ce manque de
en plus moi je voulais faire ce métier
donc j'avais envie de qu'il me passe le
lien et d'être d'avoir un rapport
privilégié avec lui c'est je me rappelle
d'une fois où il était venu à Noël on le
voyais très peu souvent moi je devais
avoir 10 11 ans et j'avais mis toutes
mes économies dans un briquet que je lu
avais acheté et ce jour-là il est venu à
Chid avata quand même il avait qu'un
cadeau pour toi CIT une espèce de
pendule horrible qui est toujours sur la
cheminée c'est terrible parce que sont
parce que ce sont toujours des détails
qui
sont passé al et ben moi il avait pas de
cadeau pour aucun de ces petits enfants
ah bon que pour moi ouais que pour toi
mais moi j'étais gâtée j'étais la
préférée moi parce que vous étiez trop
nombreux voilà j'était la seule fille
les moyens il avait les moyens il avait
les moyens c'est il a été le clown le
plus payé du monde ah bon je ne savais
pas moi mon briquet du coup je l'ai jeté
dans le lac avec son paquet cadeau dev
chez moi ça je me souviens très bien
c'est un truc qui m'é a blessé mais
qu'est-ce qu' fa ouais mais qu'est-ce
qu'il faisait de son argent tout dans le
cirque les femmes ah les femmes et oui
ce qui est amusant vous voyant l'un et
l'autre c'est que finalement vous avez
plus de ressentiments vous waren comme
si vous étiez son propre fils il en a
plus que moi parce que moi moi j'ai j'ai
j'ai eu de très très bons moments avec
Papa j'ai vu j'ai fait une tournée chez
jean- richichard j'avais déjà 35 ou 40
ans pour moi ça a été formidable je
faisais la cuisine pour mon père il m'
mené on allait en discothèque ensemble
et tout voz m'emmener dans de grands
restaurants don ça a été vraiment la
belle vie ça se passait moins bien avec
mes frères avec mes frères il n'avait
pas de contact très peu vous aviez une
relation privilégiée vous oui parce que
je lui ressemblais beaucoup de caractère
pour le métier cirque et tout ça je lui
ressemblais beaucoup j'ai j'ai passé
près de 50 ans malgré les différentes
épouses et les coupure et tout ça on
s'engueulait avec papa mais je
retournais le voir et puis comme si de
rien nétaiton B comment ça va tout ça
qu'est-ce que tu
fais avec moi ça se passait bien c'est
lui qui vous a tout appris j'ai mon
propre chapiteau qui tourne aussi et et
ce métier c'est quand même papa qui me
l'a appris et je suis très heureuse de
m'appeler Lydia Zavatar et je suis très
heureuse de d'être la fille d'Achile moi
j'ai eu des rapports plus donc je l'ai
pas connu j'ai pas eu il m'a jamais
emmené nulle part et pourtant moi
j'étais vraiment très admiratif en
demande de ça et le jour où j'ai été lui
demander il cherchait un présentateur
pour présenter son spectacle de cirque
j'ai été le voir en lui demandantc
j'avais 18 ans 18 ans oui je suis
descendu avec mon smoking dans le sac à
dos à Marseille je me rappelle j'avais
pas encore mon permis pourquoi il
faisait passer à une audition il faisait
même pas passer l'audition il cherchait
quelqu'un donc j'y suis allé au flan et
je lui dit écoute moi je passe une
audition si tu veux et si ça te plaît tu
me prends ça te plaît pas tu me prends
pas et j'ai j'ai bien bossé je l'ai fait
très bien et il m'a dit ou puis il a
pris quelqu'un
d'autre vous disant pourquoi en vous
disant pourquoi war non il m'a pas dit
pourquoi mais moi je vais te dire
pourquoi parce que N nous étions malgré
tout il était le petit-fils issu du
premier mariage déjà donc les les amis
qui entouraient papa disait si tu prends
ton Petitfils donc votre frère hein
c'est le fils de votre frère voilà si tu
prends ton Petitfils au cirque son père
va venir l'autre frère va venir ta fille
va venir et tu vas reformer le clan avec
pareil que qu'avec ta première épouse
alors pour pour qu'il n'y ait pas tout
ça il avait évincé toute la famille et
votre père parce que moi c'est la
question que je me posaer parce que
quand vous parliez d'Achile Zavata au
début très bizarrement je me disais mais
c'est son père et vous en parlez avec la
même passion mais vous avez un père
Willy votre frère oui mon père parlait
peu mais il a toujours été là il est
toujours là d'ailleurs quand et c'est
genre de famille vous savez on se dit
pas beaucoup on est proche mais ça parle
pas beaucoup je me suis pas senti épaulé
il m'a pas dit tiens essaie de quelqu'un
qui est plutôt en retrait parce que lui
je pense que déjà il a rien eu de son
père donc hop ça retransmet un petit peu
le schéma par contre moi j'ai deux
enfants et je vous assure que je j'ai
cassé direct ce truccidép ah ouais j'en
'occupe mais tout le temps je passe
beaucoup de temps avec dans ce que vous
dites on a aussi le sentiment que votre
père était écrasé par le grand-père par
achid Zavata aussi peut-être par en fait
qu'il était il a un peu écrasé tout le
monde à chilavata dans la famille je
crois que tout le monde a souffert de
parce que ça a été une très grande star
à l'époque de la près-gerre donc on a
tous été un petit peu à la ramasse
derrière je me rappelle que quand toi tu
av voulu faire carrière dans la chanson
il avait proposer à à ma tante de
changer de nom et de se faire appeler
Lydia àavaz d'inverser oui mais là là
c'était par rapport parce qu' il est par
rapport au nom de Zavata qui était c pas
d'accord he l'un et l'autre c'était pour
faire carrière ou parce qu'il ne voulait
pas que son nom il trouvait que pour
faire de la variété du chant c'était
mieux que je m'appelle pas Zavata parce
que Zavata c'était comique notamment
quand je voulais chanter pour Monsieur
Eddie barcly non vous avez voulu chanter
pour lui ou en pour pour lui pour son
père pour son père parce il se
connaissit tous les deux ah oui bien sûr
il se connaissait bien et papa me disait
tu n'es pas prête et finalement vous
l'avez rencontré son père Eddie Barkley
non jamais jamais non j'étais jamais
prête ah pour lui d'près papa j'étais
jamais
prête quand même un monopole quelque
part quoi un truc où c'était lui et pas
les moi je sens dans le spectacle il y a
des choses que je dis pour mon au nom de
mon père je sais plus trop lesquels mais
il y a des choses ou à ton nom ou au nom
de mon oncle quoi et cette colère elle
vient plus particulièrement du procès ça
a été un cataclysme quand même ce procès
le fait pas vraiment parce que nous
n'avons pas perdu le procès oui je sais
vous l'avez même gagé papa papa a été
très influent
par des amis qui lui ont dit tes enfants
profitent de ton nom c'est ce qu'on lui
a dit oui et tu devrais pas tolérer qui
s'appelle Zavata fil on nous a demandé
met un trait d'union bon d aussi ça peut
lui faire plaisir mais forcément les
médias ont dit que papa avait gagné il
avait obtenu le fait qu'après avavat
nous mettions à trait d'union peut y
avoir aussi la crainte de ne pas rester
toujours en haut de laaffiche et qu'à un
moment donné ça se termine bon pour des
raisons de santé donc je crois qu'il a
toujours sans doute le sentiment qu'on
est quand même en en équilibre en
équilibre instableah oui mais c'estàdire
que le jour où vous avez raison parce
que le jour où mon père ne s'est plus
produit le CIRC a décliné donc il était
malade il a arrêté le chapiteau tout ça
les médias ont dit qu'il avait fait
faillite c'est pas vrai il s'est suicidé
non pas parce qu'il avait fait faillite
mais parce que il souffrait énormément
et son geste vous a vous a vous a
surpris ou c'est finalement dans la
droite ligne d'un homme qui il avait dit
depuis 2 ans il souffrait tellement que
le fusil était chargé depuis 2 ans il a
dit le jour où j'en peux plus je je me
suicide parce que un un monsieur comme
lui qui qui savait tout faire qui
faisait du sport la pétanque la pêche le
bateau le truc le machin trou transigent
aussi avec les autres mais avec lui-même
app il voulait pas se sentir diminué et
de dépendre des autres ça il voulait pas
j'ai l'impression que hashzavata qu'on
voit là tout en étant absent était
justement omniprésent moi c'est ce que
je ressens surtout avec vous reen que en
fait c'était une grande ombre présente
ouais cétait encore pire qu'il soit pas
là parce qu'il y avait ces espèces de
mec au-dessus ce clown génial cet
artiste incroyable que moi je
connaissais pas finalement ça a été le
père et le grand-père de toute une
génération sauf de ses enfants enfin en
tout cas sauf de ses petits enfants mais
ça ça m'a donné une espèce de force et
de ténacité de j'ai travaillé enfin je
me suis construit tout seul mais c'est
bien aussi de se construire seul super
c'est super une sorte de thérapie ou pas
à travers à travers le spectacle même si
c'est un vrai spectacle he c'est pas du
tout un spectacle combi chose où au fur
et à mesure je vois que j'en veux de
moins en moins à mon grand-père
finalement j'ai enlevé de l'aigreur ça
me calme je me sens plus à l'aise plus
tranquille d'avoir parlé de ça et j'ai
un beau souvenir au hô de trévis j'ai vu
ma tante mon père et mon oncle qui
étaient venu un soir où tout le monde
s'est leva je les vu en face de moi
m'applaudir comme ça à la fin de mon
spectacle et ça m'a
voir les enfants d'Achile juste là pour
moi cétait cétait grand pour ne rien
manquer sur ma chaîne in mire Duma
abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche